guy lagache et ben on le retrouve alors
bien sûr on le retrouve tous les
mercredis sur des beats et obtient
d'ailleurs guy dis moi ce que j'aime
ville est toujours beau gosse regardez
franchement quand il présente enquête
d'actualité le mercredi regarder la line
up parking tout coup de lagaf' regardez
regardez comme ils vous regardent et
ghardaïa pas une autre photo mais j'ai
trouvé que cette photo des saboteurs ça
veut dire le mais clairement il est
toujours beau basse et ont trouvé la
seule photo le gars on dirait qu'il
vient de s'embrouiller avec un mec en
voiture comme et sans rigoler c'est mais
elle est pire c'est pas trop non plus
voilà voilà non vous avez vu ce que je
vais tous les jours y ait un toit ya des
gardiens via des grillons je crois qu'un
cri que oui alors à télé manger avec moi
guy abbas si je perds moi si je perds je
n'en suis qu'à se mange pas c'est ce que
disait toujours à ma femme
attention on y va à fond mais attention
alors sous disquette dans je vous dise
quête d'eau il ya des criquets des
grillons des blagues des larves des
verts et des chamallows voilà donc il
faudrait tomber sur les chabal ou quoi
on a une chance sur six est pour vous
montrer que je ne triche pas vous
choisirez ma boîte si je perds mon dit
lagache à 2,3 chez face à hewitt et la
feuille
la folle englobe la pierre et toof la
pierre la terre manquent d'oxygène
la paire d'heures lapierre moeurs
choisissez une boîte
allez-y faites vous plaisir qui dit moi
non pas vous si tu me regardes alors 1 2
3 4 5 6 l'a3 l'a3 à l'abeille la 3.0 se
trouvait découvrir sur sugar
attention je vais regarder ce qu'il ya
de vrai les chamallows sur est il à une
est non il a un cul suisse là bref les
amateurs et les chats ballon serait non
à la question c'est quoi ta chanson
préférée même chanson préférée est ma
chanson préférée de toute la vie de
toute ta vie un mouvement neuf de coeur
[Rires]
non on va relever qu'il fait des volumes
avait chanté duquel j grâce à de
nouvelles équipes
je vous fais l'étude était trop esseulé
mais pas trop j'ai crevé vrai et vous tu
vas tu étouffes et jeune équipe là non
ma gueule à la journée il a fait beau il
ne reste que des trucs dégueulasses
alors attention un chiffrement joue mais
hélas et le fuseau coupe la pierre
à
ou à prendre là sont les 320 tenir on va
prendre l'a5 aller là cinq sets dj baba
truc on y va on y va qu'est ce que c'est
que ça alors alors ça s'ouvre par là
c'est quoi ça oui regardez venez là non
mais c'est vivant les meilleurs des
platanes ont alors est ce qu'on va
manger ça plus tard guy je ne sais pas
j'ai pas enquêter là dessus et m'a mis
des plantes les bras votre place mais
non on compte la vie dont je vous avais
été là il me l'a dit vivant on peut par
un homme alors je veux bien la prendre
dans la main du quart à petit bisou à la
voilà tu fais un petit bijou la nuit une
grosse non mais franchement pas ce que
vient la vache qui rit il ya là c'est
pas se regarde ses tontons regardons se
ressent grave et c'est que ça saute
cette merde les grillons
on ne soutient pas il donnait des
risques au canada les houches et là
attention de les écraser pas écrasés par
la lady de les écraser par des grilles
on ne les écrase et pas voilà alors
c'est regarder juste un petit bisou
voilà voilà